if they steal my powers they could
conquer the universe
just like big diesel it's all about
family Tom Sonic the Hedgehog
I don't know where San Francisco is West
West rate shot can't miss here I go bye
bye I think he went too far
I'm wet I'm cold there's a fish on my
head weird little dude the time for
talking is over it's time to push
buddies you're flying eggs are pretty
impressive mr. Eggman but let's face it
you'll never catch me han fidence a
fool's substitute for intelligence
[Music]
that's not good
Sonic and then you got the SuperSpeed
and everything but Maddie and I totally
defense this is probably gonna get blown
up pretty much yeah
don't worry I know exactly what to do I
was not expecting that but I was
expecting not to expect something so it
doesn't count
oh this one is cute let's keep
so Endora be so terrible
you've got car insurance right
[Music]
buzz off that doesn't sound good
no peeking it bad get rid of it I'm
trying row it up the wind blown anywhere
I can't get it alright I'm pulling over
did I get it
no here hold still it's going it's going
it's still here
[Music]
you